hello and welcome to this video playing
in mortal wow this guy and this guy is
nine out of nine but he probably has a
chance I'm not playing well today so
let's see what happens nine out of nine
that doesn't happen that good stuff for
my here okay hmm yeah many moves
possible wonder now may I just take keep
it simple it leads to some line from the
calc an exchange
yeah Black is usually aiming for that
minority attack I'm happily going for
that I can sit inside a position yes
moon where you can go before maybe ok I
would like to like she gets night over
two nite over to see form including the
way here for 98 96
okay I'm rook be six against I have to
currently my position doesn't look so
ammonius with the 928
night on d6 is also i'm covering
covering b5 at the moment
hmm that's a good move
look sorry that looks dangerous that
looks dangerous
preparing 98 hmm that's dangerous but I
had no no good move okay 98
poor very uncomfortable maybe I need
some chat didn't see that move I didn't
see them we're all hahahaha okay oops
oops so as I said this is this hot today
is the day for all the guys who just get
a proper beating usually they can beat
me because I'm playing badly oh it's
giving me the exchange back that's
surprising what why did he do that Wow
game is back on still doesn't look great
but at least i see no I don't see
exactly how I lose now
I definite trading looks something that
I don't really like to do here but it's
difficult not to not to go for that look
86 he actually has Bishop takes b5 this
is something to take note of not a happy
move but I guess I have to okay okay
success Bishop b5 this I can play
you can take for the draw doesn't want
to probably still smells black sea air
now if you wants to win yes to take but
that that entails risks either yeah so
they of course it is it wrong but I want
to I mean let's call can i still do
something here night coming to e force
that said something
maybe I can get 98-96 here without any
problems and go from there I cannot
actually move the night this is a
problem I can go to see form
I cannot he cannot win this position
whatever you try check time warning
light age three he has to at least look
a little bit
I'd h2 could be a check
now there's no no way to win round
Harvard bra Harvard there's no way to do
anything yeah I wanted to try after he
blended the exchange back but there was
no okay so they didn't see that I just
gave it back I think it's just a draw I
mean it looks bad for black at first
because of wise activity where I think
it's a draw I can I can block everything
and I have to yeah maybe if at age five
I was hoping he takes which is really
not good for him but to get some to get
ambitious and now we just have this
total a total draw you can add also i
cannot avoid book trade so yeah I was a
pretty normal position up to a point but
then it got really ugly night h5 was
very good I have to have to have to do
something about that maybe bring the
night over here for for defensive
purposes I think something like that
should be roughly equal he's got the a
file but the c3 porn isn't great equal
ish somewhat like that and this is
getting very very dangerous he I have to
play g6 is just chance just losers very
nice and I don't know I don't know when
we was at the mouth slip no other moves
with the Rope doesn't do make any sense
he can just play a 4 and and win the
game basically technically wow I was
lucky okay thanks for watching